Here is 1 of the main priorities
and I am pleased that
for today
eh everyone accepts that we have 1 problem,
is not here,
we have 1 problem.
Now what it is time to do is to make 1 diagnosis.
and honest as to what the situation is.
In other words, made,
I do not share that the situation is
consequence of the pandemic
exclusively.
The pandemic,
far from
the lack of doctors that we have here
is not a consequence of the pandemic eh.
The situation of primary care
is not the exclusive consequence of the
of the pandemic
eh.
I think there has been 1 lack of planning,
evident that there has been 1 policy
eh of the wrong personnel
and there are political responsibilities
and they must be assumed.
What about political responsibility
eh main one is the PNV?
Yes,
because it has managed its saquidezza for 40 years.
and it is important to assume these responsibilities
to make 1 accurate and honest diagnosis
and then apply
eh,
the right solutions